hello and welcome to date up in this
video explain the value of you want you
happy valley correctly keeper watching
you want to investigate the friends of
men and women in the tourist an die
value as follows the new head offices
as well as as you that there is no  difference
in the salary of men and women in the
population in 52 53
the difference operated ok
the friends of the seventies traffic light is
ron from where do you really not
difference between men and women okay so
what can i checked in with a look at the
alfa  laval significance level of the
significance level it is the german
before the examination and must not be
changed the way to obtain results or
significant level is usability web
surft through this means that would
withdraw sample wendy foden 250 in the
cold bus speed
statistics skeleton system copy and
stamp data  and open text
bernau datatec will automatically
calculate independent samples
value
and hate online tutorials